[Music]
the family of a man who was killed
inside a nevada prison last year is now
suing the department of corrections and
its leaders this after the eight news
now i-team uncovered how there were
documented warning signs before the
brutal killing twenty-one-year-old
isaiah sharp was found stabbed inside
his cell
96 times according to the clark county
coroner court records reveal the alleged
killer andrew hilford had previously
made a threat he was caught with a
prison shank multiple times before and
he was accused of trying to attack a
correctional officer sharp's family
didn't know about any of this until the
eye team first reported it
i don't know why they would place my
brother with someone like that
and they obviously can tell that my
brother isn't like that who should be
held accountable other than the suspect
the prison the workers
according to the lawsuit four days
before he was killed the parole board
recommended that sharp be released from
prison that month he was convicted of an
armed robbery when he was 18 and
struggling with drugs andrew hilford the
alleged killer is serving 20 to life for
a separate murder